[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic je vais tenter de répondre un
maximum des questions scientifiques que
vous m'avez posé ne pouvons pas répondre
à tous j'en ai sélectionné 10 pour
chacune des trois échelles de l'univers
infiniment petit macroscopique et
infiniment grand commençons par 10 de
vos questions dans l'infiniment petit
jusqu'où peut-on aller dans l'infiniment
petit canton zoom de plus en plus il
arrive une échelle qui n'est pas bien
décrite par nos théories actuelles
à cette échelle du notion de temps et
l'espace semble ne plus avoir de sens et
on ne peut plus ou mais c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'échelle de planck
à quoi sert l'accélérateur de particules
l'accélérateur de particules va utiliser
des champs électriques et magnétiques
très puissant pour accélérer des
particules élémentaires à des vitesses
proches de celle de la lumière leur
donnant une énergie très importante et
en les faisant entrer en collision on
peut ainsi générés et étudier de
nouvelles particules beaucoup plus rare
qu'ils n'apparaissent que lors de ce
type d'événement est ce possible de
conserver de l'antimatière oui on est
aujourd'hui capable de confiner des
antiparticules en utilisant des champs
magnétiques pour éviter qu'elle ne se
désintègre en touchant des particules de
matière ordinaire qu'est ce que la
symétrie cpt
c'est une symétrie fondamental dans
l'univers les initiales cp et et
correspondent à la charge électrique la
parité dans l'espace et le temps
pour simplifier cette symétrie nous dit
que si on inverse la charge électrique
d'une particule sa parité dans l'espace
et le sens d'écoulement du temps
tout revient au point de départ est la
particule se comporte exactement comme
si on n'avait rien inversée qu'est ce
que la physique quantique et à quoi
sert-elle la physique quantique est un
modèle mathématique extrêmement précis
qui permet de décrire les objets de
notre univers à l'échelle des atomes et
des particules lé vérifier
expérimentalement avec une précision
incroyable et a permis de mettre au
point tout un tas d'objets
technologiques comme par exemple les
ordinateurs pourquoi ne traversons pas
les objets lorsqu'une pomme tombe sur
une table elle ne va pas la traversée
ceci est due à l'interaction
électromagnétique entre les atomes de la
baume et les atomes de la table en effet
lorsqu'il se rapproche les atomes vont
interagir très fortement de sorte à se
repousser
ce qui va s'opposer à la gravité et
stopper la chute de la pomme
comment un photon peut-il posséder de
l'énergie sans masse dans la nature
posséder une masse confère un objet une
certaine énergie
c'est ce qui est notamment traduit par
la célèbre formule e égal mc2 ou e et
l'énergie que possède un objet avec la
masse
m mais posséder une masse n'est pas le
seul moyen de porter une énergie
notamment le mouvement confère lui aussi
une certaine énergie
la relativité restreinte et la physique
quantique nous disent que même s'il n'a
pas de masse un photon possède une
certaine impulsion du fait qu'ils se
déplacent à la vitesse de la lumière et
donc une certaine énergie
qu'est ce que la constante de planck la
constante de planck est une quantité
propre à la physique quantique qui donne
en quelque sorte la taille des plus
petites grandeur possible que peut
porter une particule par exemple les
plus petits paquets d'énergie que porte
un photon elle définit l'échelle à
laquelle s'applique la mécanique
quantique
car c'est justement à cette échelle
qu'on ne peut plus faire
d'approximations et qu'il faut
considérer que la matière et quantifier
la gravité existe-t-elle dans
l'infiniment petit c'est une question
très intéressante car on n'a pas
vraiment de réponse oui les effets de la
gravité doit forcément avoir une origine
microscopiques mais la nature de cette
origine microscopique est encore
inconnue les nouvelles théories qui sont
élaborées comme la théorie des cordes
la théorie de la gravité quantique à
boucles ou encore la théorie des
ensembles cause on cherche justement à
donner une description microscopique de
ce qui est fondamentalement la gravité
et enfin comment un neutron peut-il se
transformer en proton en neutron est
composé de deux quarks down de charge
électrique moins un tiers et d'un quark
up de charges + 2/3 mais sous certaines
conditions un quark dan peut émettre une
particule un peu spécial qu'on appelle
le bosons w - le bosons w - à une charge
électrique de -1
ainsi en perdant cette charge le quark
dawn va maintenant avoir une charge de
plus deux tiers il s'est transformé en
quark up et le neutron et maintenant un
proton on enchaîne maintenant sur des
questions plus macroscopique à notre
échelle pourquoi l'eau s'évapore à
température ambiante en dessous de 100
degrés celsius un volume d'eau liquide
ne va pas entrer en ébullition par
contre comme notre liquide l'air
contient lui aussi des molécules d'eau
c'est l'humidité de l'air naturellement
la vitesse de certaines molécules à la
surface du liquide va leur permettre de
s'échapper pour rejoindre l'air
certaines molécules contenues dans l'air
vont al'inverse venir s'intégrer aux
liquides
lorsque l'humidité de l'air et de 100%
il y as équilibre entre le nombre de
molécules qui arrive dans le liquide est
celle qui s'en échappe
mais en général l'air est beaucoup plus
sec
il y a donc davantage de molécules qui
s'échappe du liquide que deux molécules
qui retourne et ainsi le liquide
s'évapore
quelle est l'origine des mirages sur la
route quand il fait chaud l'air à
proximité de la route est chauffée par
l'asphalté est ainsi l'air en bas et
plus chaud que l'air en eau
d'après le phénomène de réfraction la
lumière se déplaçant plus vite dans
l'air chaud que dans l'air froid les
rayons lumineux en provenance du ciel
vont être déviée jusqu'à atteindre nos
yeux
[Musique]
que sont les forces de marée lorsque
deux corps s'attirent comme la terre et
la lune étant donné que la gravité est
d'autant plus forte qu'on est proche de
l'objet attirant un côté de l'objet le
côté le plus proche va être davantage
attiré que l'autre côté en particulier
sur terre les océans et les mers sont
d'un côté très attiré par la lune il se
soulève et c'est la marée haute et de
l'autre côté ils sont moins attirés que
la planète toute entière
ils vont donc rester en retrait il se
soulève dans l'autre sens comment
obtient ton un plasma en variant la
pression et la température d'un gaz dans
des conditions ordinaires de pression et
de température on ne peut tout
simplement pas pour obtenir un plasma il
est nécessaire d' ionisé le gaz c'est à
dire de libérer certains de ces
électrons pour ce faire on peut lui
injecter un courant électrique très
puissant le bombarder avec des
rayonnements très énergétique ou encore
le placer à une température extrêmement
élevée
pourquoi les ondes radio traversent les
murs chaque matériau effet d'atomes et
les atomes sont capables d'absorber des
ondes d'une certaine longueur les atomes
du mur et de tous les objets que l'on
peut voir avec de la lumière sont
justement capable d'absorber les ondes
dont la longueur d'onde correspond à la
lumière visible mais les ondes radio ou
une énergie beaucoup plus faible que
celle de la lumière et leur longueur
d'onde est donc trop grande pour être
absorbée par le mur en quelque sorte les
atomes du mur sont sensibles à certaines
longueurs d'onde
et si la longueur est trop grande ou
trop petite alors les ondes ne seront
pas absorber
pourquoi le son est plus rapide dans
l'eau dans l'eau les atomes sont plus
fortement liés entre eux que dans l'air
en effet l'eau est plus dense et les
atomes sont plus proches
on peut se le représenter en imaginant
que les atomes dans l'eau sont reliés
par des élastiques très tendu alors que
les atomes dans l'air sont reliés par
des élastiques plus mou quand on
perturbe un atome dans l'air la
perturbation va se propager plus
lentement que si on perturbe un atome
dans l'eau si on aspire une bouteille
dans l'espace s'écrasera tél
c'est une bonne question dans le vide il
n'y a pas de matière pour exercer une
quelconque pression extérieure sur la
bouteille imaginons que la bouteille
soit remplie terre cette aire exerce une
pression à l'intérieur qu'il a fait
gonfler et quand on ouvre la bouteille
celle ci va naturellement se vider mais
elle n'a aucune raison de s'écraser
car il n'y a pas de pression extérieure
sur ses parois d'ailleurs dans le vide
on ne peut pas aspirer un récipient car
le fait d'aspirer correspond justement
au fait de créer une baisse de pression
par rapport à l'extérieur mais dans le
vide il n'y a déjà plus aucune pression
deux objets s'éloignant chacun à 90 % de
la vitesse de la lumière ne la dépassera
est il pas l'un par rapport à l'autre
imaginons deux vaisseaux qui s'éloigne
chacun à 90 % de la vitesse de la
lumière
observons maintenant la situation depuis
le point de vue de l'un des deux
vaisseaux
d'après la relativité restreinte selon
ce point de vue c'est le vaisseau qui
est immobile et l'univers tout entier
qui se déplace à 90 % de la vitesse de
la lumière
le vaisseau va donc voir l'univers
contractée dans cette direction et voir
le mouvement de l'autre vaisseau qui
fait partie de l'univers également
contracté
en relativité restreinte les vitesses ne
s'additionnent pas au lieu d'observer
l'autre vaisseau se déplaçait à 180 % de
la vitesse de la lumière le fait que
l'univers soit contracté implique qu'on
voit seulement l'autre vaisseau se
déplacer à 99,4 bourse ans d'où vient le
bang supersonique
lorsqu'un objet émet des ondes sonores
saison 2 se propage à la vitesse du son
autour de lui mais si l'objet se déplace
plus vite que la vitesse du son les
ondes qu'il aimait vont s'écraser
derrière le mouvement de l'objet formant
une sorte d'onde résiduelles qui prend
la forme d'un cône au passage de cette
onde on entend un bang
et enfin pourquoi ressentons
l'accélération mais pas la vitesse dans
un véhicule dans l'univers un objet va
avoir naturellement tendance à se
déplacer en ligne droite et à vitesse
constante
ainsi dès lors qu'il est lancé à la même
vitesse
le passager son corps et tous ses
organes internes vont se déplacer en
ligne droite et ainsi épousé le
mouvement du véhicule tant que celui-ci
ne tourne pas ou ne change pas de
vitesse pour finir quelques questions
sur l'infiniment grand et l'univers tout
entier
qu'est ce qu'une exoplanète une
exoplanète est simplement le nom qu'on
donne à une planète qui tourne autour
d'une autre étoile que notre propre
soleil la matière peut-elle être
constitué d'autres choses que des atomes
la matière et tout ce qui possède une
masse généralement elle est faite
d'atomes mais pas toujours un plasma par
exemple n'est pas formé d'atomes
il consiste en une soupe d'électrons et
de noyaux
lorsque certaines étoiles massives meurt
elle laisse derrière elle un objet
tellement dense que sa matière n'est
plus formés de plasma mais seulement de
neutrons comprimé entre eux c'est une
étoile à neutrons
comment les rayons lumineux peuvent-ils
être capturée par un trou noir
s'il ne change pas de vitesse en
relativité générale la gravité à la
capacité à ralentir l'écoulement du
temps à proximité du trou noir
le temps s'écoule moins vite qu'à
distance pour un observateur qui se
trouverait à proximité
la lumière à côté de lui se déplace
toujours à la vitesse de la lumière
mais pour nous qui observons ce rayon
lumineux depuis une position lointaine
cette zone de l'espace semble évoluer au
ralenti et donc le rayon lumineux se
déplace plus lentement
cette différence de vitesse apparente de
la lumière entre différentes zones
valade dévié et la tirer vers le trou
noir un peu comme les mirages qu'on a vu
précédemment
pourquoi la terre ne grossit pas en
relativité générale relativité générale
on entend souvent dire que ce n'est pas
la pomme qui tombe vers le bas mais le
sol qui accélère vers le haut
on peut alors naturellement penser que
la terre devrait grossir si le sol
accélère vers le haut de tous les côtés
pourtant non la terre ne grossit pas il
est nécessaire de bien comprendre la
notion d' accélération en sciences on
appelle accélération le fait de dévier
une trajectoire par rapport à son
mouvement naturel en relativité générale
le mouvement naturel des objets n'est
pas la ligne droite mais la chute libre
la pomme qui tombe est donc bel et bien
en train de suivre son mouvement naturel
elle n'est pas accéléré c'est à dire
qu'aucune action extérieure ne vient
perturber son mouvement
par contre le sol s'il suivait son
mouvement naturel devrait lui aussi
tombé mais pourtant il reste immobile
cela signifie que quelque chose
l'empêchent de tomber le sol subi une
accélération vers le haut en
l'occurrence cette accélération vers le
haut est dû à la pression répulsive
exercée par les matériaux qui composent
la terre comment l'univers peut-il
s'expose s'il est infinie imaginons une
grille des espaces cette grille est
infini où qu'on aille
elle s'étend pour toujours pourtant on
peut très bien expandent rhj à carreaux
de la grille est ainsi en augmentant
simplement la largeur de chacun des
carreaux on expose l'espace tout entier
pourquoi dit on que l'univers n'a pas de
centre reprenons notre grille infini qui
s'expose du point de vue de quelqu'un
sur terre l'expansion de l'espace lui
semblent centrés sur lui si on remonte
le temps on a l'impression que le big
bang s'est produit exactement ici mais
pour quelqu'un sur mars
le big bang semble s'être produit ici
aussi en fait où que l'on regarde le big
bang s'est produit absolument partout
dans l'espace car il ne s'agit pas d'une
expansion de quelque chose dans l'espace
mais d'une expansion de l'espace
lui-même que signifie un univers
homogène en univers homogène est un
univers qui contient à peu près la même
quantité de matière et donc des toiles
et de galaxies et qui est organisée de
la même façon avec les mêmes lois
physiques où que l'on se trouve
c'est le cas par exemple de notre
univers qui pour l'instant semble
homogène à grande échelle
mathématiquement on peut démontrer que
dans un tel univers homogène et en
l'absence de gravité les trajectoires
naturel des objets sont les lignes
droites parcouru à vitesse constante
la théorie de la relativité est elle
fiable à 100%
oui et non oui car toutes les
expériences coïncide avec les
prédictions et ce avec une excellente
précision jamais aucune expérience n'a
remis en cause ses principes fondateurs
cela dit il faut être conscient que la
relativité est un modèle mathématique
peut-être qu'un jour une nouvelle
expérience viendra la contredire
d'ailleurs il est important de
comprendre qu'en tant que modèle
mathématique elle est limitée un certain
cadre en l'occurrence les grandes
échelles si on s'intéresse à des
systèmes petit microscopique on ne peut
plus l'utiliser ce n'est donc pas une
théorie qui marche partout et c'est pour
cette raison qu'on cherche aujourd'hui à
élaborer une nouvelle théorie qui
pourrait décrire à la fois l'infiniment
grand et l'infiniment petit pourquoi
relativité et physique quantique ne
peuvent pas être réunies il est
important de comprendre qu'aujourd'hui
on s'aide unifier la physique quantique
avec la relativité restreinte
ce qui pose problème c'est la relativité
générale et donc la gravité à l'échelle
quantique tout est quantifié en quelque
sorte tout est formé de briques
élémentaires pour concilier les deux
théories
on voudrait donc pouvoir quantifier la
relativité générale c'est-à-dire
identifiés les briques élémentaires de
la géométrie de l'espace temps lui même
mais il se trouve que c'est
mathématiquement très difficile voire
impossible
certaines quantités mathématiques qui
décrivent l'espace temps deviennent
incontrôlables le mans infinie
aujourd'hui les chercheurs vise donc à
développer des théories complètement
nouvelle qui en partant d'une approche
fondamentalement différente pourrait
peut être retombé à la fois sur les
prédictions de la physique quantique à
petite échelle et sur les prédictions de
la relativité générale à grande échelle
on appelle ce genre d' approche des
théories de la gravité quantique et pour
finir l'univers est-il infini à grande
échelle l'univers possède une certaine
courbure cette courbure va déterminer si
l'univers est infini ou plutôt fine et
en effet supposons que l'univers soit
courbet à la façon d'une sphère alors
tout comme la surface de la terre
l'univers serait ainsi fini et en
marchant très loin dans une direction on
pourrait revenir à notre point de départ
al'inverse si l'univers est plat à
grande échelle
c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas de courbure
alors dans ce cas il s'étendrait à
l'infini à la façon de la grille qu'on a
vu précédemment
aujourd'hui on est capable de faire des
mesures très précises sur la courbure de
l'univers à grande échelle et pour
l'instant toutes les mesures semblent
indiquer que l'univers est plat ou tout
du moins qu'il est immensément grand
devant la taille de l'univers observable
ainsi on ne sait toujours pas si
l'univers est infinie peut-être ne le
saura-t-on jamais mais dans la mesure de
ce qu'on peut détecter
il semble plutôt infinie
[Musique]